mes chers collègues je vous propose
qu'on
relance notre commission
Monsieur le Secrétaire général pour
l'investissement
mes chers collègues nous accueillons
donc ce matin Bruno Bonnel donc je l'ai
indiqué secrétaire général pour
l'investissement depuis janvier de cette
année si mes sources sont bonnes anciens
membres de la commission des affaires
économiques de l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai appris que il y avait eu plusieurs
commissions mais en tout cas on a
cheminé ensemble dans la commission des
affaires économiques dans les deux dans
les deux assemblées et nous avons eu le
plaisir d'échanger parfois même de
batailler lors du dernier quinquennat je
me rappelle effectivement voilà de
divergence de vue quelquefois sur la loi
pacte nous ne nous pouvons que nous
réjouir qu'un parlementaire ancien chef
d'entreprise dans des domaines très
innovants comme les jeux vidéo
l'informatique la robotique ait été
désignée à la tête du secrétariat
général pour l'investissement pour je
vous cite assurer la cohérence et le
suivi de la politique d'investissement
de l'État ce n'est pas une commence à
faire que de travailler la cohérence et
le suivi des politiques publiques avant
de vous donner la parole puis de
permettre à mes collègues de vous poser
des questions je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur deux aspects ma première
interrogation porte sur la lisibilité et
la gouvernance du plan France 2030 de
multiples plans des programmes des fonds
ce sont sédimentés ces 10 dernières
années ce qui et ce qui en 2009 était
une bonne idée pour gagner en agilité à
peu à peu perdu en clarté et peut-être
justement en cohérence le dernier de ces
plans en date est donc le plan France
2030 c'est celui bien sûr qui va nous
intéresser ce matin je rappelle que le
plan France 2030 se sont 34 milliards
d'euros à proprement parler auxquels
s'ajoutent les 20 milliards d'euros de
pays A4 pour un total donc de 54
milliards le pays A4 fondu dans le plan
France 2030 était déjà le mieux doté
depuis le pays à 1
sauf si on considère les 57 milliards
d'euros du grand plan d'investissement
sous le précédent quinquennat qui lui
avait absorbé le pays à trois donc vous
voyez bien qu'on finit par se mélanger
les pédales pardon de cette expression
bref entre crédit recyclé crédit
réellement investi et crédit des
précédents plans et faits d'annonces
nous espérons que vous y retrouver mieux
que nous et surtout que les
investisseurs privés les entreprises s'y
retrouve ces derniers à l'exception des
très grosses entreprises qui sont bien
dotées juridiquement sont souvent un peu
perplexes et un peu perdu quelquefois
même rebuté par la complexité des
dossiers à déposer pouvez-vous donc nous
expliquer par qui les sélections sont
opérées et selon quel principe nous
avons connaissance d'un comité
interministériel de l'innovation d'un
comité France 2003 auprès de la première
ministre d'un conseil d'orientation
stratégique auprès du président de la
République au milieu de ces instances
quel est votre rôle quel est celui des
opérateurs quel est celui des ministères
depuis un an quelle décision avez-vous
prise pour améliorer la cohérence de
l'action de l'État et l'affaire gagner
en souplesse l'approche holistique de
l'innovation recherchée par l'État
est-elle enfin devenue réalité ma
seconde interrogation porte sur
l'efficience des investissements de
l'État dans un contexte de fort
endettement public d'après l'Insee la
dette publique que vous le savez à peu
près tous aux alentours de 3000
milliards d'euros en hausse de près de
100 milliards d'euros sur les six
premiers mois de l'année et atteint
désormais 113% du PIB et en même temps
les taux d'intérêt sont en train de
remonter la Cour des comptes a
régulièrement souligné les lacunes de
l'évaluation des précédents plan
d’investissement or il s'agit de mon
temps considérable qui dépasse parfois
les montants des missions budgétaires
classiques du PLF avez-vous dans vos
fonctions identifiez des freins par
exemple fragmentaires ou législatif qui
pourrait être levée pour améliorer
l'efficience des investissements à coup
constant c'est d'autant plus crucial
qu'il semble que la nécessité de
dépenses massive et rapide pour la
relance de l'activité à temporairement
diminuer la sélectivité des appels à
projets des pays a et du même coup de
diminué peut-être l'efficience des
investissements portés par le
Secrétariat Général pour
l'investissement pourtant censé être
stratégique les critères de sélection
ont-ils été depuis resserré quels
critères objectifs pour prioriser les
investissements de qualité long terme
s'agissant par exemple des 5 milliards
d'euros de soutien l'innovation dites de
rupture au sujet de l'exigence des
résultats vous aviez indiqué que
l'évaluation de France 2030 ne sera pas
seulement financière mais qu'elle
englobera aussi des impacts sociétaux
c'est parfait mais il me semble pourtant
important que les décisions qui engagent
les données publiques soient fondées sur
une évaluation scientifique rigoureuse
et non pas sur de simples opinions et
des intuitions qui ont pu parfois nous
égarer sur les deux derniers
quinquennats je pense par exemple à la
question du nucléaire comment donc ces
impacts sociétaux sont-ils évalués les
évaluations interne auxquels vous
procédez sont-elles ou seront telles
rendues publiques selon quelles méthodes
les 10 objectifs de France 2030 pourront
être adaptés pour tenir compte au fil de
l'eau des premiers retours d'expérience
voilà mes premières questions Monsieur
le Secrétaire général et je vais vous
laisser la parole et ensuite bien
entendu je laisserai mes collègues vos
questionnez je vous en prie merci madame
la Présidente de messieurs bonjour
effectivement dans d'une autre instance
c'est l'occasion d'être de l'autre côté
et je serai très intéressé à répondre à
toutes vos questions et je vais laisser
le maximum de temps pour cela pour
pour planter un peu le décor si je peux
me permettre de parler comme ça
le plan France 2030 il vient d'un
constat important c'est que nous le
savons tous on est non seulement dans
une transition mais oserait le dire on
est dans une métamorphose énergétique et
on va passer d'une énergie fossile qui
qui contrôle les pilote tout ce qu'on a
appelé la révolution industrielle à
l'électricité qui a une caractéristique
particulière c'est au-delà de la
puissance qu'elle maintenant qui est
maintenant comparable à celle du
thermique apporte en plus électron qui
pense l'électron qui apprend l'électron
du numérique et donc on passe en fait
d'un monde de la machine avec les
énergies fossiles à un monde qu'on
pourrait qualifier presque du robot avec
les l'énergie électrique c'est une si je
me permets de faire cette ceci en
introduction c'est vous expliquer que la
cohérence du plan France 2030 elle vient
d'une analyse qui est qui est plus
globale que simplement un enchaînement
de savoir comment on allait remettre
tous les les différents plans précédents
tous les pays précédents dans une dans
une logique il fallait absolument qu'on
change de perspective et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que le France 2032 s'appelle
pas pays à 5 mais s'appelle bien France
2030 et va intégrer totalement le budget
de 20 milliards du pays à 4 précédents
qui concerne des stratégies
dans différents domaines je vais y
revenir et dans une logique donc pour
redonner avec ces 54 milliards une
cohérence d'action à l'état puisqu'à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu ces grandes
transitions dernier en date étant
effectivement là la révolution
industrielle puis malheureusement les
reconstructions qui ont lieu après les
guerres les guerres mondiales l'État a
été déterminant pour changer la donne
pour dé risquer pour redonner de
l'audace pour encourager l'industrie
privée à repartir sur des nouvelles
directions alors
France 2030 c'est à la fois dans la
continuité des pays et en rupture totale
avec eux dans la continuité parce qu'il
y a toujours le le
SGPI donc qui était avant le CGI donc le
secrétaire général pour l'investissement
qui pilote ses plans là donc avec une
équipe compétente
depuis maintenant 2000-2009 bien
évidemment avec des renouvellements
d'équipe mais certaines d'entre eux dont
Claudia qui a mes côtés sont là depuis
l'origine donc il y a une continuité de
l'action par contre il y a une rupture
de philosophie et la rupture de
philosophie c'est que c'est que nous
allons soutenir à la fois l'innovation
et un sujet brûlant d'actualité qui est
l'industrialisation ça c'est une vraie
nouvelle donnée c'est-à-dire qu'on ne se
contente pas simplement d'aller au
prototypage mais on va vraiment de la
recherche fondamentale jusqu'à
l'industrialisation des différentes
innovations que nous supportons c'est
important il y a dans le dans le dans le
dans la famille la grande famille France
2030 il y a notamment des dossiers qui
s'appellent premier usine notamment des
trouver la projet d'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt mais le premier
usine croyez-moi allez jusqu'au produit
jusqu'au jusqu'à la fabrication des
produits et non pas simplement de
s'arrêter à cela au prototypage ou à
l'innovation donc vous m'avez demandé de
d'expliquer un petit peu la lisibilité
au-delà de la cohérence de ce plan donc
je vous ai expliqué cette cohérence elle
est dans cette transformation sa
lisibilité c'est simplement que nous
avons
réorganisé le SGPI en 5 pôles le premier
pôle est un pôle de santé dont vous avez
peut-être suivi l'actualité de vendredi
qui était la création de l'agence
innovation santé donc c'est parti
intégrante du SGPI et qui donc va
s'occuper des problématiques de santé
que ça soit les dispositifs médicaux que
ça soit les la recherche fondamentale en
santé tout ce qui nous a qui nous a
manqué pendant la crise covid regroupée
autour de cette agence innovation santé
donc qui fait partie de du SGPI deuxième
pôle s'appelle Paul transition
éco-énergétique avec
envolés un volet production d'énergie
des carbonée donc nous accélérons tout
ce qui est les méthodes de production
d'énergie des cabanais dans le
photovoltaïque dans la production
d'hydrogène des carbonées dans le les
petits réacteurs nucléaires c'est-à-dire
toute la recherche fondamentale sur des
petits réacteurs par rapport aux EPA
dont on parle aujourd'hui
le les bien évidemment tout ce qui est
du domaine du vent de l'éolien qu'il
soit en mer ou sur terre donc ça c'est
la partie géothermie biomasse donc ça
c'est à partir de la partie production
énergétique et puis à côté un budget
très très important sur ce qu'on appelle
les usages et la décarbonation du
quotidien c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est
la décarbonation industrielle la
décarbonation agricole
on y a aussi mis parce que c'est lié à
la décarbonation agricole tout ce qui
doit être du domaine de l'alimentation
une alimentation plus saine et plus
durable donc un gros pôle de transition
éco énergétique qui me paraît important
à souligner
le cœur le pôle central s'appelle
connaissance connaissance il regroupe
l'enseignement qu'il soit scolaire ou
supérieur la recherche et sa
valorisation et également la culture
pourquoi est-ce que je l'ai mis au
centre du dispositif c'est parce que je
pense que il est clef de comprendre et
nous avons un très gros budget pour les
compétences et métiers d'avenir il est
créé de comprendre que on peut mettre
beaucoup de milliards sur la table si on
ne forme pas les femmes et les hommes
pour c'est tous ces nouveaux métiers qui
nous attendent on sera en déficit comme
on l'a déjà aujourd'hui dans trop de
métiers on sera en déficit de de bras et
de cerveau pour voir véritablement les
les poivrons les mettre en place donc ce
pôle connaissant c'est d'important et il
intègre la culture parce qu'on se
laperçu c'est un mot anglais c'est un
anglicisme pardon mais le soft power
c'est à dire le la capacité d'influence
sur le plan des produits et des méthodes
et critiques et il y a souvent
culturelles donc on renforce au
contraire le pôle dans ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les industries culturelles
et créatives dans ce pôle connaissance
le quatrième pôle s'appelle le pôle de
de souveraineté numérique et
cybernétique il regroupe donc tout ce
qui est du domaine de la souveraineté
cloud cyber securité intelligence
artificielle mais également électronique
et robotique c'est dans ce pôle
notamment qui a été logé les grandes
opérations dont vous avez entendu parler
il y a quelques mois de crawl par
exemple c'est-à-dire la capacité de de
redéployer sur notre territoire sur le
territoire donc de l'Isère des
fabrications importantes de chips qui
seront critiques pour les industries
notamment les industries automobiles et
robotique parce qu'effectivement on est
un petit peu à l'oré du chemin de savoir
quels sont les chemins robotiques qui va
falloir emprunter avoir une souveraineté
quand vous savez que 80% des robots
industriels aujourd'hui sont soit
chinois soit japonais et qu'ils seront
déterminants dans les usines du futur il
est peut-être important de s'importe
s'interroger sur comment renforcer nos
positions et pas simplement logiciel sur
ces domaines là et puis le dernier pôle
parce qu'il faut donner aussi des des
projections dans l'avenir le dernier
pôle s'appelle nouvelle frontières et il
regroupe l'espace il regroupe
l'exploration des fonds sous-marins et
il a les regroupe le quantique
c'est-à-dire ces domaines d'exploration
littérale où on sait pas trop pour le
moment où va la boussole mais on sait
qu'en tout cas dans les prochaines
années dans les 10 dans les 15
prochaines années on sera certainement
ça sera certainement des zones de
compétitivité déterminantes vous voyez
cette lisibilité elle a permis de ouvrir
les guillemets rangées à la fois les
stratégies d'accélération donc elles
sont toutes celles des pays apprécients
sont intégrés sans des différents pôles
et de mettre en place les 10 objets que
le Président de la République avait cité
dans son discours de octobre dernier les
10 objets donc clé alors je vais pas
vous les lister de façon brutale mais de
tête quelques-uns qui sont assez
symboliques 2 millions de véhicules
électriques par exemple Fabr sur notre
territoire d'ici 2030 c'est un vrai défi
c'est un vrai défi complexe ça fait
partie de ces objets là 20 médicaments
bioproductions qui soient produits sur
notre territoire c'est également très
complexe parce que la bioproduction
c'est la production de médicaments non
pas à partir de chimie mais de biologie
et derrière il y a des processus très
très complexes pour mettre ça en usine
et donc un certain nombre comme ça de
projets emblématique qui qui rentreront
dans ses pôles sur je voulais vous
rassurer sur quelque chose avant de vous
expliquer comment ça marche déjà vous
dire que le plan France 2030 est un plan
extrêmement sélectif puisqu'on a une
sélectivité moyenne de 30%. ça veut dire
qu'actuellement il n'y a qu'un projet
sur trois qui soit présenté dans France
2030 qui soit qui passe là-bas des jurys
puisque je vais vous expliquer le
process qui est assez simple mais sachez
que les juges sont effectivement
scientifiques ce sont des gens qui sont
dans des compétences scientifiques et
techniques et qui sont de préférence
choisie pour être internationaux
c'est-à-dire avec une certaine distance
par rapport aux problématiques locales
et mais aujourd'hui cette sélectivité de
l'ordre de 30%. suivant les catégories
on aussi entre 27 et 32-1 donc je vous
donne un schéma un peu global sur la
comment ça marche
alors il y a la gouvernance interne et
puis la gouvernance vis-à-vis de des
bénéficiaires la gouvernance interne
elle est donc le SGPI est placé est un
est un est une direction
interministérielle placée sous
l'autorité de madame la Première
ministre et nous avons un comité de
suivi qui est piloté par Madame Patricia
Barbizet et qui regroupe d'ailleurs
bientôt je vais avoir une nouvelle liste
je crois qui regroupe des parlementaires
qu'ils soient de l'Assemblée nationale
ou ou de la ou du Sénat et des
personnalités qualifiées indépendantes
qui discutent ensemble donc je les nous
voyons tous les deux mois et nous
faisons tous les deux mois à ce comité
de suivi donc qui est une gouvernance
interne je précise nous faisons un
rapport et nous discussions de certains
des termes du pôle qui sont choisis par
la présidente du comité
à côté de ça nous travaillons avec
quatre opérateurs quatre opérateurs qui
sont la BPI l'ADEME l'Agence nationale
de la recherche et la Caisse des dépôts
est consignations ces quatre opérateurs
sont chargés par nous d'instruire des
dossiers sur des soit des appels à
projets de moins en moins soit de plus
en plus des appels à manifestation
d'intérêt la différence étant qu'un
appel à manifestation d'intérêt vise une
zone sur laquelle on veut travailler je
vous donne par exemple un une
information nous travaillons
actuellement sur un appel à projet qui
dans le nom de code c'est innovation et
haut tout simplement l'eau pour
justement ne pas restreindre tout ce qui
est innovation à quelque chose de trop
précis et de pouvoir donner l'occasion à
différentes à différentes
structures d'innovation de nous proposer
des solutions qui associent l'innovation
et l'eau je pardon
c'était pas prévu on ne fait ni bâtiment
terre ni capacitaire donc déjà nous les
bassines on finance pas
c'est vrai donc mais bon ça peut être
des techniques de
désalinisation de l'eau ça peut être des
techniques de comment optimiser les
circuits d'eau de recyclage de l'eau
dans certains cas dans certains
structures industrielles donc un
ensemble de dossiers mais ça c'est pour
vous expliquer la différence entre une
amie une un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt et un appel à projet qui lui
va être beaucoup plus précis et sur
lequel on va donner des directions et
des et un cadre qui va être beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus contraint donc c'est
c'est ces appels à projets et appelle la
maléfiction d'intérêt sont décidés alors
dans un dans une instance qui elle
s'appelle une le comité de pilotage
ministériel qui regroupe les ministères
et des cabinets
nous-mêmes
un certain nombre de personnalités
qualifiées extérieures qui sont des
experts dans leur domaine et sur lequel
donc sont
sont décidés évidemment instruits par
avance par les différents cabinets mais
sont décidés
le comité de le comité de suivi c'est
une instance interne qui a pour votre
information elle est essentielle
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur c'est comme un
conseil d'administration d'entreprise
quelque chose qui qui se gère c'est la
gouvernance interne qui vérifie bien que
nos process sont suivis on les reporte
et on est capable de donner qu'ils ont
capables de donner de challenger
également la gouvernance opérationnelle
donc ça je le mets de côté le comité de
pilotage ministériel c'est l'instance
qui va donner le feu vert aux AAP et
enfin aux appels un projet pardon et aux
appels à manifester son intérêt là c'est
le moment du départ on confie ces
dossiers à quatre opérateurs évidemment
pas aux quatre en même temps
les dossiers entrepreneuriaux sont
plutôt orientés vers la BPI les dossiers
environnementaux plus orientés vers
l'ADEME les dossiers de recherche sont
exclusivement orientés vers la NR les
dossiers plus généraux plus globaux
comme par exemple l'appel à malédiction
d'intérêt sur les compétences métiers
d'avenir sont orientés vers la Caisse
des dépôts et consignations eux ont de
faire l'information dans leur réseau de
relever les dossiers et de les instruire
et c'est un il les instruise avec des
jurés avec des jurys pardon dont les
jurés sont constitués donc minimum 3
maximum 5 personnes sur en constitution
des jurys et qu'ils ont chargé donc de
remonter les informations de donner leur
opinion afin que ceux-ci soit tranchée
par ses jurés voilà voilà voilà la
mécanique
voilà la mécanique de la de la de
l'action du SGPI aujourd'hui sur sur ses
bénéficiaires donc quelques chiffres
quand même pour illustrer mon propos à
ce jour nous avons engagé 7,5 milliards
d'euros donc depuis que je suis arrivé
depuis le mois de janvier il y a eu 810
projets soutenus je vous ai donné le
taux de sélectivité donc il y a eu à peu
près trois fois plus de de projets qui
ont été qui ont été soumis il y a eu 12
60 bénéficiaires puisqu'il y a des
projets qui sont en consortium donc
évidemment le nombre de projets va pas
avec le nombre de bénéficiaires parce
qu'il y a des distributions qui sont qui
sont différentes
il y a eu
50% des crédits à loués qui ont été à
des projets de décarbonation c'est à
dire qui effectivement diminue
l'empreinte carbone et l'objectif est
clairement diminuer l'empreinte carbone
de nouveaux process de nouvelles
formules de nouvelles manières de
travailler nous avons 45% de PME
qui ont qui sont parmi les bénéficiaires
pour mémoire il y en a que 7% qui sont
des grandes entreprises l'intermédiaire
étant des ETI des centres de recherche
des centres publics et 56% des fonds à
louer ont été en région et non pas en
Île-de-France puisque c'était un des
grands sujets
discutés parce que j'ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup parcouru les territoires et je
veille sur instruction de de alors le
premier ministre maintenant la première
ministre que on m'avait demandé
d'installer dans chaque région un comité
de suivi régional de France 2030 sous
l'autorité du préfet de région encore
une fois c'est une instance qui n'est
pas décisionnaire une instance qui
veille à ce que sur la région
l'information se fasse bien elle réunit
sous l'autorité du préfet de région la
l'ensemble des acteurs et
socio-économiques de la région du
territoire
donc voilà qui est quelques chiffres
deux derniers mots la première c'est
tout ça a été très terre perturbé par
France relance qui était un autre
dispositif qui était un dispositif
beaucoup plus guichet et sur lequel
effectivement l'automatisme de France
relance a fait que dans les premiers
mois de mon intervention au SGPI
beaucoup de sociétés
ne comprenaient pas que leur dossier
n'était pas reçu on n'était pas accepté
parce qu'il y a le mécanisme France
relance avaient un autre objectif c'est
pas sous mon autorité un autre objectif
que vous connaissez qui est
effectivement de soutenir la relance
économique j'allais dire à périmètre
égal alors que les fondements de France
2030 c'est l'innovation l'innovation
comprise comme non pas une offre un
marché mais une réponse aux demandes
sociétales nouvelles auxquelles nous
avons à faire face donc je voulais vous
préciser ça ce que j'ai eu beaucoup de
remontées notamment d'élus de mer ou de
remonter terrain sur lesquels les gens
disaient mais on comprend pas ils ont
présenté un n'a pas été reçu oui parce
qu'il y a c'est ce filtre de sélectivité
qui est critique et qu'il faut
absolument intégrer dans l'approche de
France relance
sur
vous m'avez interrogé sur les fonds de
rupture les 5 milliards de fonds de
rupture effectivement sur ces 54
milliards 10 milliards pardon 10%,
c'est-à-dire à peu près 5 milliards ont
été prélevés dans toutes les allocations
budgétaires pour constituer ce qu'on
appelle un fonds de rupture se fondre
rupture veillant à souligner la la
troisième jambe si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi du de la de la de la de la thèse
d'investissement de France mitrante la
première étant donc
aller sur sur l'innovation
transformatrice c'est important la
notion de de transformation
la deuxième c'est
d'accepter le non ça c'est la troisième
adresse c'est la prise de risque donc la
troisième jambe c'est la prise de risque
et la deuxième je viens de la perdre
parce que je vais aller trop vite la
deuxième étant
oui le la deuxième étant de consacrer
50% de
l'investissement total aux acteurs dit
émergents c'est-à-dire à tout ce qui est
PME TPE
ETI ou spin off de grande entreprise ou
acteurs acteurs qui jouent sur des
territoires d'I émergents des
territoires un peu inattendus sur lequel
il faut qu'on pousse un peu les feux je
peux vous citer quelques exemples mais
sachez que par exemple sur le le
territoire sur le Cantal historiquement
le la somme de toutes les subventions
publiques de du paysa sur le Cantal
était de 80000 euros sur à peu près les
50 milliards depuis 2009 qui ont déjà
été investis
et bien
non non mais justement j'ai la bonne
nouvelle c'est que il y a un énorme
projet à Aurillac formidable sur la
bioproduction qui dans le cadre de
France 2030 va être soutenu largement et
qui va complètement rééquilibrer ce type
de situation
au contraire c'est l'idée c'était aussi
prise de la prise de conscience que
cette innovation elle peut arriver sur
des territoires qui ne sont pas
forcément
évidents j'étais en déplacement la
semaine dernière dans Provence Côte
d'Azur
la Provence Alco d'Azur et bien dans les
dans les Hautes-Alpes c'est la même
chose il y a eu des des situations où
aujourd'hui grâce à la réflexion sur les
nouvelles énergies sur l'hydrogène sur
la capacité de de stocker différents gaz
dans dans le sol notamment dans les dans
les mines salines et notamment de
stocker de l'hydrogène et ben là il y a
un très beau projet qui est en train de
se formaliser qui est en train de se
forger et nous espérons bien qu'il aille
au bout là encore une fois ça permettra
sur ce type de territoire de relancer de
l'activité grâce à cette transformation
énergétique dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure ce ce milliard de de rupture il
est actuellement dans sa comment va-t-il
être distribué et alloué et bien à
travers de ce que nous appelons des
projets d'exception ou des special
project en anglais des projets
d'exception c'est-à-dire de voir
effectivement comment on peut
soutenir avec avec ses moyens
considérables des projets d'innovation
qui sont extrêmement décalés par rapport
au 5 pôles dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure ça veut pas dire que ça va se
faire avec une pièce levée et on va pas
jeter ça au hasard ça sert avec de
l'expertise technologique de l'expertise
scientifique pour voir si effectivement
nous nous pensons que on peut le qu'on
peut les soutenir et j'en arrive donc à
ma jambe dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure dans la thèse d'investissement
de France 2030 vous devez le savoir il y
a d'assumer totalement le risque d'échec
de l'investissement c'est important ça
veut dire qu'en faut engrais en clair
c'est nous supportons un projet en
acceptant dans le cadre de ces pour les
ruptures en acceptant l'idée que
technologiquement il n'ira pas au bout
et c'est pour ça que l'évaluation donc
j'en finis sur ce point la validation
est importante non seulement avant
travail des juré non seulement après
quand les projets seront sortis mais
surtout pendant et donc nous avons un
processus de d'évaluation permanente des
projets qui s'appellent donc un
itinéraire et qui nous permet justement
d'évaluer les chances de succès des
projets je vous citerai un seul exemple
sur le quantique vous avez 5 sociétés
aujourd'hui en France qui proposent de
fabriquer un calculateur quantique elles
sont toutes les cinq avec cinq
technologies différentes une à base de
thermodynamique une à base de
supraconducteur une à base d'optique une
autre à base d'optique mais photonique
enfin une autre un autre type d'optique
et bien comme nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui
quelle technologie a le plus de chances
que les autres parce que c'est on plonge
vraiment dans les dans l'exploration la
plus la plus absolue bien ce qui a été
décidé c'est que nous allions soutenir
les cinq nous les avons mis tout autour
d'une table pour définir les critères de
maturité de leur technologie et en
fonction de ces critères et bien nous
éliminerons progressivement les
technologies qui malheureusement ne le
donne pas la qualité de ce que nous
espérons j'ai reçu notamment dans ce
cadre là Monsieur Alain Aspect le prix
Nobel de de photonique et de physique
quantique avec qui nous en avons
beaucoup parlé l'évident que lui étant à
l'origine de la photonique et de
quantique à une petite idée de celle qui
pense être plus performante mais en tout
cas c'est intéressant de recevoir ce
type de personne qui viennent au SGPI
parler et être les avocats
technologiques de société de société que
nous soutenons donc je voulais surtout
vous rassurer sur le fait que nous
entourons d'experts d'une façon
permanente évidemment soit au niveau
national soit au niveau local avec les
notamment les les
sociétés de transfert technologies de
tous nos chercheurs les sats et
également les les structures et les
plateformes technologiques nous avons
surtout le territoire je vous
rappellerai que les les IRT les ite en
France représentent 150 plateformes
technologiques sur lesquelles là on a
beaucoup de de chercheurs en recherche
appliqués non plus fondamental qui sont
le temps de conseils pour nous voilà
j'étais un peu long pardon mais il
fallait que je vous donne une
photographie totale et évidemment je
suis à votre disposition pour les
questions
en général votre intervention aiguiser
l'appétit de nombre de nos collègues
donc on va commencer dans l'ordre de des
interpellations qui m'ont été faites et
on va commencer par Marine Noël linman
et ensuite Franck montogy donc
Marie-Noëlle est là bonjour bonjour
excusez-moi première question vous nous
avez parlé d'abord de la structure de
France 2030 et donc de votre au
commissariat ou je sais plus le titre
exact délégué bref le leader de cette de
ce pôle vous n'êtes pas parlé du tout du
commissariat général enfin du plan or on
voit bien que nous sommes dans un
mécanisme où la réindustrialisation du
pays doit être articulé entre la
mutation d'existant qui n'est pas
toujours avec des Caps technologiques
considérables mais des évolutions lentes
et nécessaires d'autres secteurs qui
sont des filières ou stratégiquement
il faut nous regagner de la souveraineté
et ça ne peut pas être que dans les
secteurs de très haute technologie il y
a toute une série de secteurs classiques
dans lequel ça s'impose et troisièmement
il y a évidemment la nécessité de ce gap
technologique en innovation et en
industrialisation or
aujourd'hui la France est dans un
mécanisme où il y a une grande
dispersion des acteurs de la visibilité
collective qui d'ailleurs entretient
doute profond sur les capacités de notre
pays à se réindustrialiser ce que
personnellement je déplore parce que
c'est aussi une nature à ne pas
encourager l'investissement scolaire
d'un certain nombre de jeunes dans ces
domaines pourtant essentiels donc
il y a pas non plus de ministère de
l'Industrie puisque il y a un ministre
de l'Industrie qui est en fait sous
dépendance de Bercy hors historiquement
on sait que l'industrie ce n'est pas
qu'une vision financière même si
évidemment c'était essentiel ça doit
être aussi lié au ministère de de
l'université enfin etc c'est en soi une
réflexion donc comment vous en tout cas
vous imaginez est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut rester dans cette espèce de
dispersion générale ou est-ce qu'il est
nécessaire de prévoir des mutations des
regroupements des articulations
meilleures et une plus grande lisibilité
deuxième sujet l'ampleur du plan bon
évidemment 34 + 20 ça fait 54 vu comme
ça ça fait beaucoup mais quand vous
divisez par 5 ça fait déjà beaucoup
moins et surtout ça fait beaucoup moins
quand on compare à ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays ou sous d'autres formes
les pays aide à l'investissement et donc
il me semble
qu'il y a quand même des besoins
financiers supplémentaires peut-être pas
sous la même forme peut-être sous forme
de de fond souverain pour la
capitalisation parce que c'est un autre
sujet qui se pose certes il faut la
prise de risque elle me paraît
indispensable si alors déjà qu'en France
on met toujours airbag plus plus
ceinture bretelle etc et que ça
bureaucratise beaucoup
il reste que notamment des prises
capitaux dans certains domaines sont
indispensables au moins pour un portage
de moyenne durée à défaut d'être un
portage de longue durée et c'est dans
bien des cas un problème extrêmement
important on le voit d'ailleurs pas
seulement pour les nouveaux secteurs
mais j'ai posé la question sur excelia
ou sur d'autres on a quand même parfois
des boîtes qui se barrent faute de
trouver du capital ou ceux de vouloir se
donner les moyens d'avoir le capital qui
l'accompagne et la BU dans ses
règlements
c'est en fait un accompagnateur
facilitateur des banques donc elle n'a
pas cette mission en tout cas elle ne
veut pas la prendre pour l'instant donc
je je vous interroge et sur les sommes
en question vous nous dites du coup il y
a que un tiers des projets qui sont
retenus on peut dire youpi c'est
sélectif mais on peut se dire pourquoi
il y a deux tiers qui passent à côté de
la de la bande alors soit ils sont
vraiment nuls ça évidemment il faut pas
les prendre soit ils sont de moindre
priorité par rapport à vos critères et
c'est quand même pas c'est quand même
normal qu'on veille à essayer de les
aider est-ce que de ce côté là un
travail avec les régions un travail avec
d'autres mobilisations financières ne
seraient pas une méthode pour éviter en
plus la grande démoralisation des gens
en question et enfin mais peut-être que
mes collègues qui ont participé à la
mission innovation recherche en
parleront on a quand même un immense
problème d'investissement en recherche
quoi qu'on en dise le programme de
recherche que nous avons financé ne nous
amène ni aux 2% de recherche ni ou 1% ou
je sais plus combien de pour la
recherche publique et on arrive à
mécanisme on est très en retard par
rapport à nos plus grands concurrents
notamment l'Allemagne donc j'ai
l'impression quand même pour nous
annonce est très grosse somme et puis
quand on regarde au bilan des courses
l'investissement de la France pour ça
rien industrialisation ne me paraît pas
à la hauteur de l'enjeu qui pourtant est
considérable une retard
merci Marie-Noëlle Franck Montauger
ensuite Daphné rakmadou merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur Bonnel pour
votre présentation d'un sujet
complexe un gouvernance quand même très
très compliqué je trouve oui je suis là
je suis là
j'aurais trois trois petites questions
d'ordre d'hiver mais au préalable vous
avez vous avez évoqué les objectifs en
matière de de mise en service de
véhicules électriques
nous quand on discute avec les
fabricants de véhicules électriques ils
nous disent leur inquiétude sur la
question du déploiement des réseaux de
bornes de charges des véhicules
électriques on est on est parti pour
développer on a donné des objectifs
extrêmement forts à ces entreprises de
et au niveau du réseau on est vraiment à
la traîne et la situation est
particulièrement inquiétante donc
j'aurais voulu savoir si ça fait partie
des choses que vous
que vous prenez en compte après j'aurais
une question générale sur les
l'évaluation de l'efficacité de votre
action
vous l'avez évoqué j'ai pas bien compris
au regard de quels critères
je dirais politique de politique
industrielle vous procédez à ces à
l'évaluation finalement de la de
l'action de votre secrétariat général
quelle est également la l'articulation
que vous faites que vous opérez avec la
dimension européenne
de la plupart de la plupart de ces
projets je pense en particulier au pieds
comment comment tout ça s'articule parce
que c'est quand même en tout cas pour
moi c'est pas c'est pas très clair et le
dernière question sur la le thème de la
souveraineté nationale et en particulier
dans le domaine des données du numérique
on sait que les producteurs de données
ne sont pas la plupart de temps ni
européenne ni français ils sont
États-Unis ou ou asiatique est-ce que
dans ce domaine là vous avez à travers
les projets que vous ne prenez en charge
une action spécifique parce que là aussi
chaque fois qu'on rencontre des
opérateurs ou français ou européens en
matière de Cloud etc ils nous disent
tous qu'on est complètement à côté du
sujet et qu'on reste dépendamment du
monde entier pour dire les choses de
manière un peu un peu simplifiées voilà
merci merci Franck Daphné ratmadu
C voilà et ensuite de
j'ai eu le bonheur de participer à un
projet du pays A4 et le dernier paysa
contenait déjà quand même une grosse
part d'investissement et de passage à
l'échelle dont vous avez parlé
et ces pays-là se déroulent en général
sur 10 ans donc en fait il y a toute une
phase de développement du paysa y
compris 10 ans et compris l'évaluation
je veux savoir comment en fait ces
derniers paysages vont se chevaucher et
comment ça va
s'interpénétrer avec France 2030 pour
assurer en fait parce qu'on sait que les
pays a évoluent que les projets évoluent
quelquefois sont transformés il y en a
qui sont rajoutés etc et comment on
assure le passage et glissement entre
les deux
de manière connexe dans ces pays-là il y
avait une dimension très intéressante de
vous laver de consortium c'est-à-dire de
projets qui soient portés qui soit
scientifique de passage à l'échelle mais
qui soit aussi porter par les
territoires et donc il y avait une part
d'investissement mais une part de
subvention aussi
sur sur les projets territoire donc
savoir s'ils sont pérennisés voilà parce
que tout le monde y gagne à ce que
localement
ces pays-là soit et ses projets soient
d'investissement soit porté et dernier
élément sur les jurys en fait vous avez
ciblé en fait des juris scientifiques
dans le jury du pays A4 qui me semblait
aussi intéressant c'était la mixité en
fait des membres du jury qui venaient du
monde scientifique du monde de
l'entreprise ou industrielle et aussi
des élus donc cette ce regard mixte
était vraiment important et notamment
pour l'objectif d'industrialisation et
d'ancrage dans les territoires
merci Daphné Dominique Estrosi Sassone
qui est ici ensuite Françoise Ferrat
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Secrétaire général pour l'investissement
quelques questions très très diverses
donc vous avez parlé de l'évaluation
c'était une question bien évidemment que
je voulais vous poser parce qu'on sait
que dans le pays
44 % seulement des actions ont été
évaluées et on sait aussi que dans notre
pays malheureusement il y a un manque
cruel d'une culture de l'évaluation donc
vous avez pour partir répondu à cette
question sur l'évaluation en amont
pendant et après
d'autant plus que voilà ce qui vous est
souvent reproché ou ce qu'on a pu lire
c'est que vous êtes présenté un petit
peu comme l'homme qui dépense nos sous
vous êtes aussi on a souvent mis en
avance aussi en avant la question d'une
potentialité gabegie budgétaire qui a
été donc souvent montré alors comment
est-ce qu'on peut l'éviter est-ce qu'il
y aura aussi un contrôle
a posteriori au niveau en dehors de
l'évaluation par exemple est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer que la Cour des comptes
soit susceptible de faire un contrôle
par rapport à ce qui aurait été engagé
est-ce que ça a déjà été évoqué
quel rôle joue François Bayroux
aujourd'hui à vos côtés même s'il est au
commissaire aux plants mais voilà donc
il est particulièrement discret
il a parlé d'une ardente obligation à un
retour au plan qui est défendu par
François Bayrou en octobre 2021 est-ce
que les investissements que vous avez
d'ores et déjà engagés depuis le début
de l'année sont compatibles avec la
mission dont on a du mal un petit peu en
définir les contours de François Bayrou
et puis des questions plus précises il y
a pas grand chose sur le logement dans
le France 2030
hormis peut-être la rénovation
énergétique mais on voit aujourd'hui
qu'il y a une véritable crise du
logement dans notre pays et en
particulier au niveau de la construction
de logements donc est-ce que il y aura
des aussi possibilité d'action en tout
cas de de projet qui puisse être soutenu
dans ce domaine là et sur la formation
est-ce que vous aussi vous pensez qu'il
puisse y avoir des investissements qui
puissent être fait sur les formes sur
les structures existantes pas uniquement
sur ce qui pourrait être mise en œuvre
je pense par exemple au niveau des
lycées professionnels ou par exemple des
écoles de la seconde chance moi-même
présidente de l'école de la seconde
chance dans mon département dans les
Alpes-Maritimes et est-ce que vous
pensez que dans ce point de vue là il
puisse y avoir des aides ou en tout cas
des projets qui puissent être conduits
dans ce domaine là merci Dominique
Françoise Ferrat qui est elle aussi en
face de nous et ensuite Marie-Christine
Chauvin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Secrétaire général dans votre
intervention vous avez cité l'agence
digne de relation à la santé je
souhaiterais savoir si les
nanotechnologies étiennent une place
prépondérante alors même que les
chercheurs prévoient ce que l'on appelle
le marché mondial de la nanomédecine et
celui-ci atteindrait plus de 482
milliards de dollars d'ici à 2027 avec
un TCAC de 11,9% entre 2020 et 2027 avec
un tel potentiel d'amélioration des
soins patients et de la santé humaine la
nanomécine est une priorité pour de
nombreux entreprises de technologie
médicale même si on le sait elle est
difficile à développer pouvez-vous nous
donner quelques indications à ce sujet
merci
merci beaucoup Françoise Marie-Christine
Chauvin merci madame la Présidente
ma question est en lien avec celle que
ma collègue vient de poser au niveau de
l'Agence de la santé nous avons déjà en
France de nombreuses agences dont on a
la Haute Autorité de la santé on a
l'Agence nationale de la santé qui se
décline en aéré sur les territoires
comment comment allez-vous articuler
tout ce système donc quand mon collègue
Montaugé disait gouvernance compliqué
moi aussi elle me semble très très
compliquée votre gouvernance et quand on
parle de création d'agence on a toujours
certaines craintes parce qu'on sait que
déjà certaines agences qui sont sur le
terrain ont des fonctionnements
compliqués je parle pas forcément de la
santé mais d'autres agences qui ont déjà
des fonctionnements compliqués donc
quand j'entends une nouvelle agence
excusez-moi j'ai certaines inquiétudes
surtout vu au niveau de la santé déjà
d'autres qui existent comment comment
vous allez faire coordonner et
fonctionner ensemble ceci je vous
remercie il y a deux mots qui
hérissent les sénateurs en règle
générale c'est agent et rapport ça c'est
Bernard buy ensuite Christian Redon
Sarrasi merci présidente monsieur
secrétaire général le Salon de l'Auto à
Paris rappelle que la production de
batterie électrique en France est un
ajout de souveraineté industriel le 20
octobre dernier un investissement de 600
millions d'euros a été annoncé pour
développer une usine de batterie dans
les hauts de France d'autres projets
devraient être validés s'il est prévu
des investissements de secrétaire Réal
général pour l'investissement pour la
production de batterie électrique
française qu'en est-il des
investissements dans les bornes de
recharge source de préoccupation
légitimes des usagers je rejouais mon
collègue Franck derrière moi le process
de France 2030 fonctionne avec un centre
de ressources qui flèche les candidats
éligibles au projet aux appels à projets
la question de la simplification des
procédures se posent et pourrait amener
à dissuader certains petits acteurs
comment pouvez-vous faciliter simplifier
la procédure de ces appels à projets et
enfin une dernière question concernant
le spatial le premier comité de pilotage
ministériel du volet spatial de France
2030 a annoncé les 15 premiers lauréats
des dispositifs lancés dans ce cadre
cette réunion a permis de tracer les
orientations pour les mois à venir la
priorité est à l'autonomie d'accès à
l'espace le premier appel à projet a
concerner les micro lanceurs ces petites
fusées capables de placer un orbite des
charges inférieures à 500 kg la France
est en retard dans ce domaine par
rapport au Britannique Albin et bien sûr
les Américains ces investissements
vont-ils nous permettre de rester dans
la course spatiale je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Bernard alors il va
falloir se tourner un peu par là
Christian Redon sarrazzi qui est
complètement
dans les objectifs que vous qui sont
déclinés en trois axes et donc plus
particulièrement pour la question mieux
comprendre rien ne semble prévu pour la
forêt et les membres pour ta essentiel
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et qui souffre de nombreuses
problématiques nous les connaissons la
gouvernance la stratégie de gestion mais
surtout un manque criant d'ingénieur
forestier qu'en est-il donc de leur
formation et surtout de tout le volet
recherche particulièrement central pour
l'étude des essences adaptées aux
nouveaux contextes climatiques mais
aussi aux nouveaux usages de la forêt et
donc sur ce volet recharge rejoins bien
sûr les propos de ma collègue quant à la
faiblesse des moyens qui concerne la
forêt mais aussi bien d'autres nous
l'avons vu dans la mission recherche
effectivement que je préside bien
d'autres secteurs mais comment pour ce
secteur particulier de la forêt
envisagez-vous de les intégrer
et notamment dans le cadre des amis que
vous portez
merci
Fabien gay qui est là-bas sur ma gauche
et ensuite Daniel grimillac qui sera
complètement sortie madame la Présidente
Monsieur Bonnel bonjour
la mission que vous remplissez d'une
grande importance moi je crois que après
la crise du covid qui a montré toutes
les limites que nous avions d'une
politique de désindustrialisation sur
les 20 30 dernières années montre qui a
besoin je pense de planifier de se
redonner des priorités extrêmement
fortes
et c'est ça j'ai un peu de mal à
identifier dans vos propos c'est à dire
c'est quelle priorité nous nous donnons
et sur quel domaine précisément
certainement viennent de dire par
exemple spatial moi je partage sur le
domaine de la santé par exemple on avait
un champion français européen mais on
n'a pas été on a été un foutu de sortir
un vaccin donc c'est une question et
puis je pense que sur le domaine
industriel il y a pas qu'éviter en
réalité les délocalisations il y a
besoin de focaliser et puis il y a
besoin de toute la chaîne de la valeur
parce qu'aujourd'hui par exemple si on
prend les voitures
l'automobile pardon et moi
même si en bout de chaîne on en
construit quelques-unes
on ne construit pas toutes les pièces et
on est extrêmement dépendant de la
grande usine du monde donc moi c'est ça
qui m'intéresse et pour le coup je
repose la question après ma collègue
Marie-Noël linman et Madame Estrosi ça
sonne c'est quel en fait quel débat vous
avez et avec le Haut Commissariat au
Plan bon il y a des mots qui ont été dit
gentiment qu'on se faisait discret c'est
plus que discret c'est à dire que depuis
deux ou trois ans une note sur la
question de la natalité c'est ça le
bilan pour l'instant mieux au
Commissariat au Plan bon il y a
alors vous avez des informations
monsieur Bonnel donnait les nous ça ira
plus vite donc il y a besoin de savoir
comment tout ça s'harmonise et et se
construit et puis la deuxième chose je
vais plus rapide rien de personnel mais
vous nous avez expliqué alors moi je
suis je suis moins intelligent de la
bande ici j'ai fait pas beaucoup
d'études
mais je n'ai rien compris excusez-moi je
n'ai rien compris la gouvernance j'ai vu
des sourires là en plus il y a si on
fait une interro surprise à la sortie je
peux vous assurer moi j'aurais toujours
une mauvaise note mais je suis pas sûr
que un d'entre nous est la moyenne sur
la gouvernance non je vous assure on a
eu beaucoup de faim moi-même j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à comprendre les comités
qui décident quoi comment tout ça
s'agencent non je dis ça pourquoi et je
fais sourire il y a juste une chose sur
les comités d'experts moi je fais
toujours vigilant je suis pas dans le
populisme il y a des comités d'experts
des technocrates par contre il y a
besoin de pluralisme
dans ce comités d'experts et par exemple
le comité d'espères du groupe du SMIC
Gilbert 7 avec ses quatre camarades au
tous plus libéraux les uns que les
autres il y a pas beaucoup de pluralisme
et là aussi moi je pense qu'il y a
besoin d'aller chercher sur cette
question la reine industrialisation par
exemple et je finis par là puisque vous
vous tournez beaucoup moi je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup d'intelligence ouvrière
dans ce pays et il y a des gens qui ont
des choses à dire et en premier des
ouvriers des ouvrières donc par exemple
comment on arrive à les associer avec
d'autres pour pour reconstruire cette
France industrielle je pense qu'il faut
pas les oublier je regarde un peu vite
fait là le comité d'experts je pense
qu'on est loin de pluralisme je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux voilà je vous
remercie
merci Fabien Daniel grimillac qui est
complètement sur la droite et ensuite on
terminera par Martin Berthet si j'ai
d'autres domaines
quatre questions la première
effectivement il faut faire des choix
seulement
pour l'avoir vécu mais je pense que je
suis pas le seul non le vice sûrement
dans nos territoires on a des projets
quasiment identiques qui sont pas
retenus
et vous parlez des collectivités
régionales mais avec quels moyens elles
n'ont aucune dynamique financière leur
permettant de combler et donc on arrive
dans une forme de distorsion
terrible d'avenir en fonction de ses
choix
cette semaine
un débat sur les EnR ma question elle
est simple
tout vos travaux seront-ils en cohérence
avec les choix politiques que nous
sommes en train de faire nous sommes en
train d'accélérer est-ce que ces travaux
nous permettront effectivement de
produire les investissements nécessaires
aux honneurs dans notre territoire
dans notre territoire ou dans l'Union
européenne mais dans notre territoire
sinon ça n'a pas de sens on est à
l'envers troisième question c'est
et je rejoins ce qui a dit notre
collègue Christian tolère sur l'aspect
forestier je vais pas en rajouter
beaucoup je vais juste dire je suis
surpris que mais je pense que il y a
sûrement quelque chose qui se passe
ça représente quand même un tiers
quasiment de la surface de notre
territoire c'est du renouvelable
où on est y a-t-il quelque chose sur
tout ce qui est la chimie verte
d'origine forestière
et puis
mon dernier point
est-ce qu'on va
comment
envisagez-vous que toute la recherche
innovation se concrétise par
effectivement une production
industrielle dans notre pays en clair ne
pas recommencer d'éventuelles aventures
que nous avons pu vivre avec le cirque
ou effectivement des moyens publics ont
été mis ici considérables pour faire la
recherche et ensuite l'exécution
industrielle ne s'est pas traduite dans
notre territoire
merci Daniel et la Savoie pour terminer
avec Martine Berthet merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Secrétaire
général j'aurai deux questions la
première est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser vous avez dit dans vos propos
que les projets enfin un projet sur
trois et retenu examiné actuellement par
des juges scientifiques plutôt
internationaux pour éviter les
interférences
sur le territoire français donc est-ce
que vous pouvez nous préciser votre
votre pensée et qu'en est-il voilà
exactement ma deuxième question porte
également sur l'agence innovation en
santé comme mes deux collègues
précédemment alors c'est très bien
d'avoir une agence effectivement puisque
l'on veut plus de souveraineté produire
plus mais
quelle relation avec le ministère de la
Santé avec les autres agences quelle
relation quand je pense précisément à
l'article 30 du PLFSS qui prévoyait que
le gouvernement fasse des appels
d'offres pour les médicaments qui
allaient distribués alors des appels
d'offres qui bien sûr aller retenir les
moins dix ans j'imagine que c'est pour
cela c'est à dire des médicaments
fabriqués en Inde en Asie du Sud-Est
voir aux États-Unis mais en tout cas qui
ne répondent pas aux exigences que l'on
doit avoir actuellement
heureusement nous avons été plusieurs
intervenir et ce point était enlevé du
pellet FSS mais voilà je ne comprends
pas comment alors que vous êtes dans
l'idée de cette agence innovation en
santé pour pouvoir avoir des
fabrications françaises vous parliez de
vins bio similaires fait sur notre
territoire comment d'une part ces
produits auront accès au remboursement
quand on voit comme c'est compliqué sur
l'innovation thérapeutique encore
maintenant et comment des personnes
peuvent encore penser mettre ça dans des
PLFSS pour favoriser les productions qui
viennent de l'étranger je vous remercie
voilà Monsieur le scolaire général des
questions nombreuses voilà je vous
laisse répondre et on vous laisse plus
de 5 minutes
je suis désolé en 5 minutes je vais pas
y arriver mais je vais essayer d'aller
vite sur
des questions simples
nanotechnologie oui
c'est ça que je dirais qu'ils sont
simples ça fait exactement partie de ce
qu'on appelle les projets spéciaux j'ai
visité un laboratoire à Besançon qui
s'appelle femto que je vous invite
d'ailleurs un jour à découvrir
extraordinaire laboratoire ou on
travaille sur des micros robots en
photonique ils sont pilotés par la
lumière qui vont chercher les cellules
une par une chez un patient cancéreux
qui leur injecte grâce à donano
technologies de l'ADN particulier pour
les transformer et qui sont des
médicaments qu'on peut quasiment
qualifier de miraculeux sur certaines
pathologies de la leucémie notamment
donc un la France n'est pas en retard je
voudrais tuer quand même quelque chose
que j'ai trop entendu autour de cette
table la France n'est pas en retard faut
arrêter de marteler ça et d'en faire
l'amplification des médias qui
n'arrêtent pas de vous dire qu'en est en
retard je suis un spécialiste pardon de
me mettre un peu en avant mais quand
même d'un certain nombre de technologies
notamment dans la robotique dans
l'électronique dans le software dans
l'interactivité je peux vous dire que la
France est en avance sur de très
nombreux domaines par contre vous avez
tous raison sur un point nous manquons
considérablement de moyens et ce n'est
qu'un premier pas moi j'espère que la
réussite de France 2030 entraînera un
France 2040 la France 2050 et que
d'autres prendront le relais parce que
si l'état n'intervient pas massivement
comme des risters et bien nous aurons
toutes les conséquences que vous avez
évoqué ici c'est que la société privée
regardera le court terme et regardez ce
qui se passe ce matin j'ai lu hier j'ai
ouvert les échos et j'ai eu quoi bah que
le projet safran de redéploiement en
région Rhône-Alpes d'une nouvelle usine
qui a été annoncée par le président de
la République et étant pardon à l'époque
le député de la circo je l'ai accompagné
et mise en pause mais pourquoi est-il
mis en pause parce qu'il y a aucune
anticipation on dit les coûts de
l'énergie vont et beaucoup trop
importantes on le met en pause la mise
en pause
ces trois ans ça veut dire que d'ici là
bah oui effectivement le projet safran
il passera avec perte des profits donc
je rejoins monsieur gay parce qu'avec
qui je me suis déjà quelquefois opposé
sur des plateaux rappelez-vous ou sur le
fait que effectivement l'intervention de
l'État est importante je ne parle pas
politique là je voulais vous dire je
suis dans mon rôle de directeur
d'administration centrale je suis juste
en train de vous dire que je voudrais
tuer auprès de vous dans cette
commission l'idée que sur un certain
nombre de secteurs nanotechnologie en
étant photonique je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure on était un autre la France est
comment finance ça grâce au fond de
rupture c'est ce qu'on appelle les
projets dit spéciaux parce qu'ils sont
pas dans la carte donc première chose
assez rapide deuxièmement la forêt la
forêt est totalement intégrée dans notre
plan messieurs je tiens à vous rassurer
simplement elle n'est pas dénommée forêt
elle est dans la masse qui est quand
même qui doit représenter 2,6 milliards
d'euros de tête de justement une
agriculture décarbonée dans laquelle
justement va exploiter la chimie verte
de la forêt et donc toutes ces
conséquences ce qui mais il y a des nous
avons de très beaux projets d'innovation
en forêt aujourd'hui qui sont en analyse
et moi je suis je serai ravi on a
notamment financé un
une installation dans la dans la alors
je sais plus c'est l'Ardèche ou l'aube
je sais plus pardon j'ai tellement de
dossiers je sais plus et on a on vient
de financer une nation de CO générateur
très importante pour que justement les
gens qui travaillent et qui exploitent
la forêt puissent utiliser les déchets
de la forêt pour chauffer eux-mêmes et
faire le séchage des planches enfin bon
il y a tout un cycle d'innovation très
intéressant donc je vous rassure c'est
bien dans le plan par contre c'est
peut-être pas suffisamment clair et je
vous donnerai à titre individuel les
informations plus précises le troisième
le logement vous avez raison on fait pas
on finance pas de logement comment le
finance pas de bâtiment d'usine comme
mon fils en pâte capacité par contre on
fait tout le reste des carbonations des
grandes des grands producteurs de ciment
pour faire des logements qui soient
justement à moins d'impact carbone
aujourd'hui
tout le travail de ce qu'on appelle les
démonstrateurs de ville durable dans
laquelle nous finançons des actions
spécifiques d'usage de toutes ces
technologies il y en a 39 en France
aujourd'hui on a 39 en France
aujourd'hui donc des territoires dans
lequel on dit ok on va mettre des on
soutien sous forme de subventions
généralement on soutient les initiatives
de promoteur ou d'autres personnes pour
montrer que on peut loger autrement il y
a notamment des zones sur lesquelles on
a des grandes réflexions sur le
pavillonnaire à transformer en zone de
résidence partagée pour optimiser les
flux l'énergie etc donc encore une fois
je suis vraiment prêt chez dossiers là à
vous à vous mettre en face de nos
spécialistes qui vous parleront
précisément les EMR
vous allez à côté de moi Claude Girard
qui est qui est en charge en plus de
plein d'autres choses chez nous de du
photovoltaïque on met effectivement on
se cale bon moi la loi Duralex c'est de
l'ex c'est vous maintenant c'est moi je
suis plus en charge donc chacun son
boulot évidemment qu'on la mettra en
cohérence avec ce qui va être décidé
dans les dans les prochaines dans les
prochaines semaines ou les prochains
mois dans les différents dans les auprès
des parlementaires mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que non seulement on
sera en cohérence mais on fait tout pour
recréer une chaîne complète de
fabrication en France de la cellule de
la de le dire du silicium la cellule le
module la fabrication des panneaux parce
qu'on sait que c'est clé ces clés cette
chaîne maintenant nous ne faisons pas
d'idées je rebondis sur la remarque sur
les appels d'offres ne nous ont aucune
idée si on continue à avoir une
stratégie d'appel d'offres dont le prix
et le critère
on va à la cata oui mais ça veut dire
que c'est plus subtil que ça c'est bien
qu'on a joué avec des règlements
européens avec des problématiques de de
trouver des nuances dans la priorité et
notamment la nuance c'est quoi notre
pari c'est l'innovation c'est que les
technologies sur lesquelles travaillent
Claude aujourd'hui et qu'on veut
soutenir bah ça va nous permettre de
dire si c'est pas telle techno prend pas
ça tombe bien c'est pas des techno
chinoises donc ça permet de d'être un
peu plus souple sur les genoux mais
voilà le type d'approche qu'on veut
avoir alors ça c'était les cas facile
maintenant on attaque les cas difficiles
vous n'avez rien compris à ma
gouvernance je vous la simplifie
je vous la simplifie
les gens les bénéficiaires on va partir
de l'autre sens le bénéficiaire
suis peut regarder sur France
2030.gouv.fr l'ensemble des appels à
projets ils appellent à manifestation
d'intérêt avec un système de
multicritères donc j'ai je suis à une
entreprise PME TPE etc je dis tiens j'ai
envie de montrer j'ai envie de m'aider
vous mettre sur mon innovation d'accord
encore une fois sur mon innovation pas
sur le doublement de ma capacité de
production pas sur la construction d'un
nouveau bâtiment je regarde j'y tiens ça
tombe bien je veux répondre à tel appel
d'offres et il y a avec cet appel
d'offre l'opérateur qui s'en occupe donc
je l'ai dit BPI Adem etc j'envoie mon
dossier il est instruit
et on a une réponse ça c'est la partie
bénéficiaire nous maintenant sur la
partie contrôle du travail du
bénéficiaire on exige que 50% de ce
travail soit sur les je les dis les
acteurs émergents et 50% de ce travail
d'allocation budgétaire soit sur de la
décarbonation
significat enfin la décarbonation en
tout cas que la totalité soit neutre
mais quand tout va 50% face baisser
l'empreinte carbone terminé et puis
maintenant moi avec mon équipe nous
avons une instance de contrôle qui
s'appelle ce fameux comité de suivi qui
nous donne son avis maintenant que j'ai
fait simple je fais compliqué
non maintenant je fais parce que j'ai
une réaction très importante sur les
territoires
tous les préfets de région reçoivent à
l'avance tous les préfets de région
reçoivent à l'avance les programmes
d'ami d'appels et d'appel à projet
ils ont maintenant depuis la semaine
dernière c'est un bleu qui est sorti la
semaine dernière ministère de
l'Intérieur l'aura délégué au niveau
régional un sous-préfet à
l'investissement dont une partie du
travail c'est la c'est la c'est France
2030 une partie un simplement ce n'est
pas un sous-préfet France 2030 c'est un
sous-préfet à l'investissement et dans
chaque département il délègue une
personne préfet de région délègue une
personne auprès des préfets de
départements qui eux sont chargés de
diffuser cette information la recueillir
et nous faisons une expérimentation en
région provençale-côte d'Azur nous
allons même aller jusqu'à préqualifier
des dossiers pour qu'il remonte
nous voulons travailler avec les
territoires d'une façon profonde
charge au préfet mirmant qui est donc le
préfet de la de la de la région
provençale-côte d'Azur d'organiser cette
préqualification comme il l'entend
et je vous rejoins monsieur gay sur la
diversification je vous annonce aussi en
scoop que j'ai pris la décision de
mettre des jeunes un jeune par jury quoi
qu'il arrive un jeune étant une personne
volontaire
quelle que soit son origine mais qui
soit jeune parce qu'on nous travaillons
pour les générations futures et je dis
que l'avis d'un jeune sera important moi
je suis prêt à l'ouvrir à d'autres
choses mais j'ai pris cette décision de
dire maintenant il nous faut un jeune
dans dans ces juridiques pour apporter
de la justement de la diversité je pense
qui on aura des on aura des choses
surprenantes et ça m'intéresse de voir
comment les juris réagissent à ça ce
monsieur Gueye et jeune
il est plus jeune que moi en tout cas il
est plus jeune que moi c'est pour ça
qu'il est impétueux comme ça
maintenant le rapport avec avec le plan
c'est une question que j'ai entendu
plusieurs fois bon je voudrais pas me
mettre en difficulté politique en face
de cette assemblée parce que c'est pas
mon rôle faut juste vous dire que nous
avons des rapports permanents avec le
plan au niveau des équipes c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des échanges le Haut
Commissariat au Plan est constitué d'un
foyer une petite dizaine de personnes je
crois nous sommes 45 à augpi avec des
spécialistes verticaux et qui ont des
échanges avec les gens du plan voilà moi
j'ai moi-même des rendez-vous réguliers
j'en ai eu deux avec Monsieur monsieur
Berrou sur lequel effectivement il faut
qu'on mette en cohérence nos deux
actions mais je la je voudrais vous dire
quelque chose qui va peut-être vous
choquer je ne considère pas que France
2030 soit un plan
je considère que France 2030 c'est la la
mise la mise en perspective d'une
nouvelle société dans laquelle tous ces
nouveaux objets vont apparaître comme
indispensables dans une réflexion de
souveraineté comme je vous l'ai entendu
dire Madame LUMANN qui était important
mais on compte sur les territoires pour
remonter les projets
et moi je n'arrête pas de dire aux gens
proposer des projets nous n'avons pas
assez de projet pour pour justement ne
pas et c'est pour ça que je voulais
parler tout à l'heure de de limiter les
AP les appels à projets par rapport aux
appels à ma mission d'intérêt parce que
on compte sur les territoires pour
amener des projets et pour répondre ce
que je j'essaye de répondre à toutes les
questions en même temps pour aller vite
vous m'avez parlé beaucoup de formations
je peux vous dire que je suis bluffé de
la dynamique de l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt sur les compétences et métiers
d'avenir nous avons reçu dans la
première relève 85 projets dans la
deuxième nous avons reçu 300
et là pour la troisième je pense qu'on
va dépasser les 500 et alors tout le
monde c'est ce que j'allais dire j'ai
entendu la question tout à l'heure
nous avons des structures existantes
nous avons des créations de nouvelles
écoles nous avons des augmentations de
promotion nous avons des CFA et des
structures professionnelles nous avons
des entreprises qui veulent créer leur
propre écoles Renault notamment
convertir 10000 de ces de ces
techniciens à du thermique à
l'électrique ils sont ils sont ils font
partie de ce type de d'organisation donc
nous avons du privé nous avons du public
mais nous avons donc nous cherchons à
être très très ouvert encore une fois
c'est le projet et la capacité plutôt
que la structure qu'il apporte qui nous
intéresse gros succès gros succès de
cette amie
sur
la simplification question importante
vous avez raison c'est un plan que je
présente pour la fin de l'année pardon
d'avoir mis un peu de temps mais vous
avez raison de dire que on a eu un
héritage assez lourd puis on a eu un
changement de gouvernement enfin il y a
eu pas mal de choses qui sont mais nous
visons à une simplification
à destination des PME et TPE et ETI
qui viserait en fait à faire un projet
en deux étapes une étape si je peux en
parler ainsi de de d'exécutif summery
comme des Américains c'est à deux pages
dans lequel le projet est exposé et on
peut répondre très vite ce projet rentre
ou ne rentre pas dans les clous de
France 2030 rentre ou ne rentre pas dans
les coudes 2030 et s'il rentre pas bon
bah du coup le nom est très rapide donc
là la société n'a pas rentrer dans un
cycle complexe d'investissement et
notamment de de captage de captage de
budget dont elle a bien besoin par des
spécialistes de la chasse aux projets et
par contre si elle est éligible encore
une fois nous cherchons avec les CCI
avec les pôles de compétitivité avec les
structures territoriales nous cherchons
à apporter une crédibilité donc on fera
une lettre disant ce projet est éligible
il a une chance afin que la TPE ou la
PME puisse se faire accompagner dans
l'élaboration du dossier final alors
attendez maintenant soyons bien clair la
sélectivité d'une façon faciale va
forcément diminuer pardon on va
augmenter mais on va diminuer enfin vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est que
puisque nous préqualifions des dossiers
pour isaient plus de chance de réussir
au bout de la route on aura plus de on
aura plus de dossiers qui vont réussir
et mais ça veut dire que notre notre
modèle sera plutôt vertueux on va aller
vers des dossiers qui seront qui seront
toujours meilleurs donc voilà le ce que
je vais vous dire pour la simplification
ce sera en place je pense au tout début
de l'année prochaine ça a présenté en
fin d'année pour quand même en termes de
de d'autorité ça soit validé on est en
train de travailler dessus mais ce sera
ça sera fait deuxième chose que nous
faisons sur la simplification nous avons
demandé au préfet de région à travers
une circulaire que d'ailleurs je
pourrais vous communiquer il y a elle
est absolument pas confidentielle
puisqu'elle est diffusée
nous avons demandé à ce qu'il y ait du
repérage du pré repérage par rapport aux
informations qu'ils ont sur les appels à
maïssistance d'intérêt et les appels à
approcher qui sont diffusés puisqu'ils
les auront à l'avance donc ils peuvent
ils peuvent cibler certaines entreprises
en les encourageant à être candidate
sur
les les évaluations et leurs critères
les évaluations nous les nous les menons
en interne mais nous avons l'intention
de les diffuser publiquement
à savoir en tout cas que les critères de
les différents critères et les
différents indices auxquels nous
arrivons seront à partir de la fin de
l'année j'espère j'avais optique été
trop optimiste j'allais dire ça sera
fait en octobre on n'y arrive pas pour
le moment c'est on a trop de données on
a trop d'opérateurs qui ne travaillent
pas avec les mêmes avec les mêmes
systèmes d'information nous sommes en
train de regrouper tout ça et j'espère
que d'ici la fin de l'année on sera à
même de vous apporter effectivement des
des éléments beaucoup plus tangibles sur
ces évaluations elle elles sont assez
arbitraires pour être honnêtes avec vous
je préfère vous le dire c'est à dire
qu'en gros on a on a fait une liste
d'indice alors dedans il y a
développement territorial est-ce que ça
a eu un impact sur le développement
local quand on aide par exemple une
entreprise à restructurer est-ce qu'il y
a une meilleure appétence ou un meilleur
équilibre entre les hommes et les femmes
qui travaillent dans le secteur qui est
qui a été soutenu nous avons comme ça
les dressé une liste qui vous sera qui
vous sera soumise moi je suis preneur de
tout complément de cette si on estime
qu'il manque des immenses des critères
mais il a bien fallu que je pars sur une
base donc il y a une dizaine une dizaine
d'indices qui est comme ça cherchent à
regarder
est-ce qu'elle est l'impact sociétal et
non pas juste économique puisqu'en terme
de d'économie je peux pas vous dire dans
une main on joue l'audace le risque et
finalement on sait pas à quel terme on
va voir en retour sur investissement en
tant qu'État et vous dire c'est mon tri
enfin mon taux de retour sur
investissement qui va compter on n'est
pas on n'est pas un V6 privé et j'en
viens
à la remarque de Madame linman sur sur
la capitalisation il y a d'autres
structures de l'État il y a la PE ça
existe mais nous avons nous à peu près
10 milliards historiques qui vont monter
à 12 de fonds propres dans le plan
France 2030 c'est-à-dire qu'en fait nous
nous mettons bien de l'argent en fonds
propres alors pas en direct nous ça
passe généralement par la Caisse des
dépôts et conciliation qui le transmet
elle-même à des fonds ce sont des fonds
de fonds dans les fonds dont vous avez
entendu parler il y a des fonds comme
Ecotec des fonds comme spi
des enfants qui s'appelle French tech
souveraineté avec lequel par exemple
nous avons fait l'opération pour éviter
que sanofie
ce qui avait décidé de libérer ses
usines de pharmaceutique pour éviter que
ça passe dans d'autres mains que celle
de la souveraineté nous avons participé
à la recapitalisation des usines de
médicaments sur une somme considérable
pour dire on voit que ça reste en France
on veut que ça reste parmi nous donc
nous avons aussi une action à fond
propre je voulais vous le dire alors
allez est-ce qu'elle est suffisante je
suis assez d'accord avec vous que non
mais c'est pas notre mission et est-ce
qu'il faut penser non mais c'est pas
notre mission ça veut dire je peux pas
dire je vais mettre les 54 milliards en
fonds propres donc on est dans une zone
vous voyez de l'ordre de de d'une de 16%
à peu près du total
qui va être dédié en fonds propres c'est
déjà un bel effort et évidemment nous
travaillons à des effets de levier j'ai
oublié de vous préciser que l'effet de
levier moyen public privé de l'action
trans 2030 c'est une notification par
trois c'est à dire pour les 54 milliards
on a en gros 200 milliards d'impact sur
sur l'économie c'est-à-dire que en fait
on s'aperçoit que le privé bien en
renfort évidemment de du dérive de
l'État
qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié de graves les
deux tiers de projets qui passent pas
1 on n'est jamais exclu définitivement
de France 2030 c'est à dire qu'on peut
se présenter une relève suivante en
tenant compte des remarques qui ont été
faites par les jurés donc ça veut dire
qu'en gros on a une chance de revenir ça
explique d'ailleurs en partie par
exemple dans CMA dans compétences et
métiers d'avenir ça explique pourquoi il
y avait de même amplificateur pour une
partie il y a des gens qui se
représentent on n'avait pas compris ça
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont pas soutenus
parfois
eux ils ont pas compris l'innovation
transformatrice dans ce cas là ils sont
éliminés sur le fond des fois ces choses
beaucoup plus bêtes ça a fait rire
monsieur gay c'est la gouvernance qu'on
ne comprend pas
donc
parce que comme ce sont des consortiums
il faut les inviter quand ils font des
consortium à être bien clair cela
gouvernance j'ai reçu personnellement
plusieurs dossiers d'écoles dans
lesquels il y avait pas de directeur
d'école on allait faire une espèce de
gouvernance partagée entre 4 ou 5
centres ça ça marche pas oui c'était
innovant mais là ça marchait pas c'est
il a fallu leur dire de retravailler la
copie et notamment messieurs un très
beau projet d'école sur la forêt
un très beau projet qui vient d'Avignon
j'étais à Med Agri et ses occasions je
les ai rencontrés
qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié d'important
spatial et Cours des comptes
spatial encore une fois ce qui se passe
dans le spatial
c'est pas encore une fois c'est
malheureux nous étions jusqu'à une date
relativement récente sur de la
coopération spatiale européenne on l'a
tous vécu on est on est on a trouvé ça
formidable et on voit bien que Ariane ne
serait pas ne serait pas né avec tout ça
et nous a donné quand même une certaine
autonomie de cette coopération passe à
une coopétition en clair que l'Allemagne
l'Italie notamment décidé de se remettre
au micro lanceur rassurez-vous hein on
est tous au même niveau à l'heure où on
parle on est tous au milieu si ce n'est
si ce n'est
que le choix que vont faire l'Italie et
l'Allemagne pour des raisons qui sont
pas les nôtres peut-être pour des
raisons de différence de perception des
États-Unis s'ils vont utiliser des
technologies américaines et notamment
celle de SpaceX pour se poser la
question de comment ils vont rattraper
un certain retard que nous avons
justement paradoxalement dans le domaine
du militaire sur des sur des micro
lanceurs donc la bataille du new space
elle commence elle commence vraiment et
elle est critique parce que évidemment
et nous le souhaitons tous elle est
dédiée au développement de la science et
à l'exploration de l'espace civile mais
elle a quand même elle est
fondamentalement derrière dans la
dualité militaire et aux heures
relativement sombres qu'on est en train
de vivre
les pays ont choisi c'est ça ils sont
souverain pour le faire la France
comprise de maîtriser leur technologie
de micronor donc en tout cas ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que c'est déclenché
il y a un centre de budget
complémentaire à cela qui sont pas les
miens qui à mon avis viennent en appui
sur ces micro lanceurs je n'en ai pas
connaissance donc je peux avoir j'ai
mais je trouvais ça logique et qui fait
que de la même manière je l'ai dit pour
la nanotechnologie je ne pense pas à
l'heure où nous parlons qu'on puisse
parler de retard sur l'espace dans ces
domaines là dans ces domaines là
évidemment je ne parle pas de de gros
lanceur ou autre chose qui de toute
façon nécessiteront d'être d'accord sur
un plan continental
sachez qu'il y a actuellement une grosse
base dans les pays scandinaves qui est
en train de s'organiser pour devenir une
base de lancement de micro lanceur et
que justement on travaille activement
avec eux pour être bien sûr qu'on aura
nos slots dans ce domaine
sur
je vous dis toutes mes notes là oui sur
la Cour des comptes
on est déjà suivi par la Cour des
comptes c'est pas c'est pas une surprise
on est régulièrement audité et contrôlé
par la Cour des comptes donc
rassurez-vous il y a aucune transfert
d'ailleurs
sincèrement pour en avoir fait beaucoup
de rapports de Cours des comptes je vais
dire dans différents stades de ma vie on
voit bien qu'ils sont durs et c'est très
bien ça nous permet de nous améliorer je
m'attends jamais avec rapport de la
collision qui disent formidable super
boulot c'est au contraire ils vont dans
les détails ils vont le critique et je
ne peux pas prétendre qu'on soit qu'on
soit parfait mais en tout cas sachez
qu'on est bien on est bien là dessus et
j'aurais finir avec le Salon de
l'automobile et les automobiles je crois
que j'aurais je crois que j'aurais
répondu à peu près à tout
pardon
la pause
mais l'automobile
une de mes passions dans la vie c'est
l'histoire industrielle c'est vraiment
une de mes passions
le passage du cheval à l'automobile en
France ça a mis 65 ans
c'est à dire entre le moment où la
première automobile est apparue et le
moment où on a par décret arrêter le
fait que les chevaux pouvaient cohabiter
avec les voitures dans la rue il s'est
passé 60 ans
le phénomène thermique électrique ça va
être la même chose
quand je dis ça va être la même chose
c'est qu'il faut ni être il faut être
lucide par rapport au futur d'ailleurs
ce que dit la Commission européenne
c'est des voitures à zéro émission CO2
deuxième phénomène d'histoire
industrielle pour la mise au point de
l'essence ça nous paraît tous banal
aujourd'hui l'indice d'octane 85 90
parce que vous voyez là le fameux 95 et
tout ça a mis 30 ans
au départ on partait on partait de
pétrole brut voir ont distillé dans son
jardin c'est personne sait posé la
question comment rouler les premières
automobiles électriques il y avait pas
de pompe il y avait pas de pompe il
fallait trouver de l'essence
et c'était du bidouillage et moi je vous
dis aujourd'hui je pense que les bornes
électriques sont du bidouillage
aujourd'hui parce que évidemment que
nous sommes tous d'accord que passer une
demi-heure à charger sa voiture un 15
août sur l'autoroute ça va être un petit
problème et si vous voulez les queues
qu'on a vu aux pompes là à cause de
cette foutue grève c'est une blague on
va passer notre vie à dire qu'est-ce que
tu fais aujourd'hui bah moi aujourd'hui
le rechargement bagnole c'est mon job de
la journée on pourrait demander à
Monsieur bonus
non mais ça c'est pour non mais ça c'est
pour vous expliquer que faisons
confiance à la technologie qui va
considérablement évoluer à la fois la
technologie des batteries rappelez-vous
les premiers téléphones portables que
vous aviez
vous aviez des durées de vie vous disiez
mais c'est pas possible ça marche jamais
votre truc
pour ceux qui ont connu le Bebop à Paris
on se posait la question mais si on
s'éloignait à plus de 200 mètres de la
borne ah ça marchait plus donc faites
confiance à la techno sur l'automobile
là où je suis pas d'accord avec ni
monsieur Tavares et je lui ai dit
directement
surtout monsieur Tavarez d'ailleurs je
suis pas d'accord il y avait les mêmes
débats les mêmes débats existaient quand
les voitures sont apparues en France il
y a même un livre que je vous recommande
à les trouver sur Amazon il est très
rare mais je l'ai je pourrais vous le
prêter oui bah sur Amazon parce que
parce que je sais pas où vous pouvez le
trouver d'autres parce que il est il est
il est très très rare ou sur leboncoin
plutôt parce qu'il y a mon avis elle a
pas eu beaucoup
il s'appelle chauffeur chauffeur pour
parce que chauffeur vient de chauffard
et on disait les voitures vont écraser
tout le monde il faut surtout pas il
faut pas stimuler l'industrie automobile
c'est une catastrophe faut surtout pas
le faire
l'énergie électrique c'est l'énergie de
demain
j'ai commencé mon propos avec ça et je
voudrais le finir avec ça et demain oui
il y a plein d'obstacles technologiques
assumé
mais vous savez quoi peut-être que le
véhicule de demain n'est pas le véhicule
automobile d'aujourd'hui
en tout cas en Chine se développe ce
qu'on appelle les véhicules
intermédiaires sont quelque part entre
le vélo électrique et la première Zoé en
termes de prix sont des machines à 7 7 à
10.000 euros
voire 4000 parfois vous avez raison
peut-être peut-être qu'une partie de nos
concitoyens dirons moi finalement je
vais louer une voiture pour le weekend
puis j'aurai un petit véhicule comme ça
ils ont déjà commencé quand ils achètent
des vélos électriques ils changent de
méthodes de mobilité donc moi je pense
que si on croit qu'on va reproduire le
schéma du thermique dans l'électrique on
se trompe maintenant ça n'enlève pas le
fait qu'on dépense quand même 300
millions cette année dans les dans le
développement du réseau de bornes
électriques n'oublions pas pas cette
année dans le plan pardon ne l'oublions
pas et enfin sur votre souci sur les
applications industrielles ça c'est mon
boulot de tous les jours ça veut dire
que nous on veille
il faut pas il y a deux erreurs à pas
faire la première erreur
la science est inépuisable et je pense
que ceux qui pensent que le monde est
fini en termes scientifique se trompe
considérablement et je dois vous avouer
que ma rencontre avec Monsieur aspect
m'a fait découvrir un autre monde
il y aura une révolution quantique
réelle
qu'on ne verra probable pardon pour les
plus jeunes mais peut-être aucun d'entre
nous la verra et vraiment je dis pardon
pour les plus jeunes parce qu'elle est
peut-être à l'échelle de 50 60 et
peut-être un siècle mais il y aura une
révolution quantique c'est certain c'est
une nouvelle manière de voir le monde
qu'aujourd'hui même on a du mal à
comprendre
comme il y a une comme il y a une
révolution électrique il y a une
révolution quantique et ça veut dire que
il faut pas négliger la science
fondamentale il faut continuer d'une
façon têtue à mettre de l'argent dans la
science ou les chercheurs cherchent et
trouvent pas forcément parce que ça
c'est important de creuser Sion
maintenant je suis d'accord avec vous
que l'heure est grave en termes
d'industrialisation et que nous notre
job en dehors de ce budget là que je
veux vraiment isoler dans Sciences
fondamentale qui revendrait 10% de c'est
à peu près 10% tout confondu si on va
dire fondamental fondamental et les
premières applications théoriques tout
le reste doit être mis sur
l'industrialisation et moi plutôt que
parler de réindustrialisation ou de
relocalisation j'ai mieux parler de Néo
industrialisation parce que je pense que
quand je visite les territoires et que
je vois des aciéries qui commencent à
dire on va passer au four électrique
moins de CO2 des cimenteries commencent
à dire on va faire du ciment avec des
technologies qui vont diviser par 10
l'énergie dont on a besoin et il sera
tout aussi solide tout aussi efficace
quand je vois des technologies fines qui
permettent de dire on va pouvoir faire
du plus du sur mesure mais en industriel
plus du sur mesure avec des
usines qui sont plus concentrées plus
petites et qui vont être
c'est pas mon objectif mais qui vont
forcément réaménager le territoire sur
les petites villes parce que c'est là
qu'on va retrouver de la compétence
notre problème collectif il est pas là
moi j'y crois tout ça notre problème
c'est l'appétence des jeunes à la
science
ça c'est notre vrai problème nous avons
actuellement dans l'Est de la France par
exemple de très nombreuses formations
professionnelles professionnalisantes et
industrielles rempli à 40%
non mais ça c'est typique parce que là
on a pour le coup c'est des machines
outils des machins qui ont coûté une
blinde à la France et il y a pas les
gens donc là je pense que ça c'est le
noeud du problème il est de redonner
confiance à cette jeunesse dans une
science qui soit plus propre qui soit
qui soit plus plus vertueuse pour la
planète et qui leur permettent de vivre
avec des salaires décents donc de gagner
en compétitivité clairement par
l'innovation voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire et je vous remercie de toutes
vos questions pour les si vous avez des
questions et je tiens à vous dire dans
mes messieurs les sénateurs si vous avez
des questions précises n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer à me les communiquer par
écrit je me ferai un devoir de vous y
répondre parce que je pense que j'ai une
mission territoriale essentielle et vous
en êtes les relais donc moi je je compte
vraiment répondre à chacune de vos
questions dans le détail s'il le faut et
mais je pense que c'était bien que je
vous donne un peu le cadre même si j'ai
pas été aussi bon en pédagogie d'après
monsieur gay que prévu mais j'ai fait
mon possible merci
très bien merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Secrétaire général merci beaucoup pour
cette présentation j'avais deux trois
petites questions résiduelles mais je
voulais poserai comme ça merci pour
cette présentation merci à mes collègues
pour leur curiosité je vais demander à
mes collègues de rester deux petites
secondes parce que j'ai voilà deux
de nouveaux amendements à vous à vous
soumettre voilà merci beaucoup merci à
tous